er kannte der wendler sagt sie haben
sich einsichtig gezeigt dass es falsch
war ihnen als verrückt zu bezeichnen
stimmt das
natürlich sehr häufig gesprochen diese
woche und im grunde genommen nicht
umgekehrt dass er schon viele dinge
verstanden hat sich gesagt habe ich habe
ja in der oliver pocher sendung von
cramm gesprochen letzte woche ich bin
kein mediziner das kann man natürlich so
oder so sehen aber in der abfolge der
nachrichten ich bekomme auch letzte
woche donnerstag und dann auch freitag
seine audios die ja gewusst habe ich mir
natürlich schon gedanken gemacht ob da
alles in ordnung ist wie waren denn
jetzt die reaktion auf ihre aussagen der
letzten tage vor allem von den fans sich
denen ja immer sehr stark hinter ihrem
wendler ja das teilt sich natürlich das
ist ja schon immer so gewesen wenn
michael wendler dass die meinung zu ihm
sehr stark auseinanderdriften
es gibt sehr viele fans gibt auch sehr
viele die ihn nicht mögen hier in dem
fall ist es ist es genauso und ja es
ging bei mir natürlich auf sämtlichen
kanälen auch von bedrohungen
beschimpfungen bis zum motto natürlich
war alles dabei und ja das muss man
jetzt durchstehen und aushalten damit in
dieser branche sich bewegt dann weiß man
doch was man sich einen das vorher wenn
man das nicht weiß dann ist mir glaube
ich auch forderungen sind trotzdem
natürlich keinen spaß auch wenn sie
jetzt sagen das gehört zum job dazu hat
ihre beziehung zu michael wendler durch
all dieses chaos jetzt und durch seine
aussagen einen knacks erhalten
das weiß ich nicht ich habe ja versucht
nach amerika zu fliegen das ist ja
aufgrund der aktuellen situation jetzt
leider nicht möglich man kann ja nicht
einreise aufgrund der kona maßnahmen und
deswegen war es immer nur möglich
telefon oder per facetime zu
kommunizieren ist natürlich noch was
anderes wenn man sich in die augen
geguckt und gewisse dinge bespricht
nichtsdestotrotz habe ich meinen
standpunkt ganz klar deutlich gemacht
und habe auch mitgeteilt dass ab ich
habe diese woche sehr viele termine
gehabt mit mit juristen mit anwälten mit
partnern
ich glaube die ein oder andere brücke
wurde ihm jetzt gebaut da muss jetzt
einfach nur drüber laufen und ich hoffe
für ihn dass hat die fonds nutzt weil
ansonsten glaube ich wird es dann eben
dann auch eng man muss sich davon
positionieren und wenn man weitermachen
will in sieben wochen in dieser branche
und das habe ich ihnen dringend
angeraten und bin selber ist auch seine
entscheidung gespannt er kann die
wichtigsten fragen die wir uns
eigentlich alle stellen ist michael
wendt dann noch immer so überzeugt von
dieser muss sie einfach so einen
absurden theorien wie bisher die er
bisher verbreitet hat also ist schon von
vielen dingen abgerückt allerdings ist
es so dass er natürlich zu gewissen
themen eine meinung hat die die
natürlich sehr sehr konträr gesehen wird
von mir auch ich habe mehr als einmal
gesagt dass ich diese thesen alle nicht
teilen kann und dass ich man kann
trefflich darüber diskutieren ob jetzt
beherbergt verbot oder so sinnvoll oder
und sinnvoll ist in deutschland das sind
alles sachen die glaube ich auch otto
normal bürger manchmal nicht verstehe
die man besprechen kann
aber sind natürlich ein paar thesen
dabei die sind für viele leute nicht
ganz so verständlich die nicht so
politisch denken und die sich mit dem
thema nicht so tief auseinandersetzen
und es ist grundsätzlich glaube ich
immer ein fehler wenn sich ein sportler
oder künstler politisch äußert oder wenn
er sich politisieren lässt das ist hier
jetzt michael wendler passiert und die
konsequenzen erleben wir gerade seit
einer woche alle glaube ich ganz
deutlich eine der konsequenzen die er
für sich selber gezogen hatte er hatte
gesagt er will nicht mehr zurück nach
deutschland kehren
der ist es besonders dann interessant
wenn man davon ausgeht er muss
eigentlich zurückkommen denn es steht
ein prozess an bei dem man sich selber
zeigen muss haben sie mit ihm darüber
gesprochen wie das jetzt weitergehen
soll
ja ich muss da ein bisschen das regieren
der prozess der in die gestern
vorgestern war wurde schon vor zwei
monaten mit dem gericht besprochen dass
der verschoben werden muss denn
eigentlich jetzt dsds gewesen wäre ein
tiroler offen teilte er auch abgesagt
und ist dieser termin wurde jetzt
versuche ich glaube in den dezember ich
das wüsste ich gerade kopf habe dann
muss er sich natürlich verantworten und
ich hoffe und glaube dass er das auch
machen will
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren